today i'm gonna be turning myself
into an instagram filter when i look at
myself in these filters it almost feels
like that's how i'm supposed to look i
got some temporary tattoos
from a tattoo artist who actually makes
temporary tattoos and then i have some
tattoos from amazon very excited also a
little nervous but
it's gonna be great
oh now okay should i do sparrows on my
chest and something on my neck how do i
know if they're even uh what do i want
to put on my neck do i want to put a
flower on my neck
do i want to put this flower on my neck
well i don't know
all right we're doing it me trying to
commit to a temporary tattoo was hard
imagine me trying to commit to a
permanent tattoo
not great okay so that didn't work user
error do i do the sparrows on my neck no
i definitely want to do those on my
chest all right we're gonna do this one
first this one's going here say
absolutely still for best results
absolutely
you know i bet that first one didn't
work because i kept moving
these are gonna be uneven and i'm gonna
be upset i think okay i'm going for it
well they're not exactly even but
they're not not even listen i tried okay
all right i'm doing it i'm staying still
nope didn't stay still this then i gotta
imagine staying still when you're
getting an actual night touch i don't
know how people do it i really don't but
if this doesn't work i'm gonna have to
rethink the whole neck tattoo situation
um
that's pretty cool this is sick wow my
mom is not gonna know what to do with
herself so now
let's do
a big shoulder girl
that's the coolest thing i've ever seen
wow
really just turning myself not only into
an instagram filter but just the coolest
version of myself that has ever existed
[Music]
this is so cool i mean like what that
looks so real okay so i know i want to
interchange
these flowers and then the peonies
little guy right here
i think this is where this one comes in
tell me i forgot to take the plastic off
remember to take the plastic off
let's put one big old peony right here
now i'm gonna add this one
take the plastic off
i've never looked cooler in my life
okay so a big part of the instagram
filters are the face tattoos so i'm
a little nervous about that
i'm gonna put a rose tattoo right here
i hope this looks somewhat good
oh boy
it does look like the filter
i want to put something here
is it me or is it an instagram filter
me i'm an instagram filter now all right
seth
oh my god
post malone that's pretty cool though is
it yeah you like my neck hat i do
i like everything yeah i like the two
birds too you do yeah so how long do
they stay on for i don't know until i
can figure out how to take them off i
guess i've never felt cooler i look like
some people's real life but to me i look
like an instagram filter i put those
filters on because they make me feel
good and they make me like look good but
i feel like i look good
right now
i might have to get some tattoos i am
realizing upon taking my makeup off the
face tattoos do not stand a chance
against the makeup pipe obviously i
already lost my little sparrow goodbye
face tattoos
now i do not think that the rest of the
tattoos are going to come off that
easily someone said the best way to get
temporary tattoos off is
tape
oh
[Music]
you